Muchos nos habéis pedido que hagamos un vídeo
hablando sobre BRASIL y la catástrofe política
y económica por la que está pasando este
país.
Pero antes, voy a contestar a otra gran pregunta
que nos habéis hecho en muchos correos y
que está relacionada con este otro tema.
Como sabéis, VisualPolitik, lo fundamos entre
tres personas: Alberto RFC, Enrique Couto
y yo, que me llamo Fonseca.
Y muchos nos habéis preguntado ¿Cómo nos
conocimos?
¿Éramos amigos antes incluso de crear este
canal?
Pues lo cierto es que sí.
Precisamente, nos conocimos en un seminario
titulado PERSPECTIVAS MACROECONÓMICAS DE BRASIL.
Era el año 2012 y por aquel entonces, casi
todos los expertos decían que Brasil era
el país del futuro.
Recuerdo que estábamos en Santander, en el
Norte de España, y conocimos a varios economistas,
politólogos y hasta algún ex presidente.
Todos ellos estaban de acuerdo en que Brasil
iba a convertirse en un país rico, más de
200 millones de habitantes, la mayoría de
los cuales empezaban a formar parte de una
pujante clase media.
Por aquellos años, empresas españolas como
el Banco Santander o Telefónica estaban invirtiendo
miles de millones en conquistar el mercado
brasileño ¡No sólo eso!
Lula da Silva era una rock star tanto para
los analistas de izquierdas como para los
de derechas.
Un modelo de político capaz de combinar crecimiento
económico con políticas sociales.
Sí, amigos de VisualPolitik… en aquel curso,
cualquiera que dijera que Brasil no tenía
futuro, era tachado de loco.
Cinco años más tarde, Lula da Silva ha tenido que pasar por la justicia.
Su sucesora, Dilma Roussef tuvo que dimitir
de su cargo.
El actual presidente está acusado por cargos
de corrupción y Brasil está en recesión
económica.
La inseguridad en las calles ha llegado a
tal punto que el ejército ha tenido que desplegar
tropas en ciudades como Río de Janeiro para
evitar guerras callejeras.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Cómo hemos llegado hasta
aquí?
¿Qué ha pasado para que Brasil haya pasado
de ser la gran promesa de Latinoamérica a
ser hoy una auténtica debacle, tanto a nivel
político como económico?
Hoy, en VisualPolitik, vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes, vamos a ver un
poco de historia.
EL PAÍS DE LAS NUEVE DIVISAS
Tal cual como lo oís.
Desde los años 40 hasta finales del siglo
XX, Brasil pasó por nueve divisas distintas.
Primero tuvieron el real, después pasaron
a tener otra moneda que se llamaba el Cruzeiro,
luego tuvieron el Cruzeiro Novo, luego Cruzeiro
otra vez… En los años 80 volvieron a cambiar
su divisa por otra, que se llamaba el Cruzado,
que también fracasó y tuvo que ser reemplazada
por el Cruzado novo…
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué Brasil ha tenido
tantas monedas distintas?
¿Es porque les gusta coleccionar billetes?
No.
La respuesta es la inflación.
Bueno, en realidad, aún peor que la inflación…
la HIPER inflación.
Durante décadas, los brasileños se acostumbraron
a que su dinero valiera menos que los billetes
del monopoly.
Entre los años
80 y 90, este país llegó a registrar inflaciones
de más del 4000% interanual.
Eso significa que si un día te tomas una cerveza
en un bar de Sao Paulo y pagas, vamos a decir,
100 cruceros.
Al año siguiente, cuando vuelves al bar,
esa misma cerveza cuesta 400.000 cruceros.
“Brasil estaba apartada del mundo.
Aislada del centro… era considerada parte
de la periferia.
De la periferia del mundo”
Hablamos de un país que ha sufrido una de
las dictaduras militares más salvajes de
la región.
Dictadura a la que sucedieron gobiernos
democráticos pero extremadamente corruptos.
Lo cierto es que, durante décadas Brasil
se dedicaba a pedir préstamos al mercado
internacional.
Préstamos que pagaba imprimiendo dinero.
Eso generaba más y más inflación ¿Y qué
hacían para remediarlo?
Pues… cosas tan ridículas como aprobar
leyes que prohibían que subieran los precios.
“Brasil ha intentado frenar la inflación
congelando los precios en las tiendas.
El Gobierno esperaba que otros gastos como
las materias primas y las ventas al por mayor
también bajaran de precio.
Pero eso no se ha llegado a materializar.
Los economistas de hoy en día dicen que Alicia
vive en una especie de “Alicia en el País
de las Maravillas”
Sin embargo, en el año 1994, las cosas cambiaron
radicalmente… en ese momento, el gobierno
nombró a un nuevo ministro de finanzas…
“FERNANDO HENRIQUE CARDOSO”
Cardoso fue el principal arquitecto del progreso
de Brasil.
Este hombre sabía que los comercios no subían
los precios por capricho.
La inflación es un fenómeno monetario.
Y por tanto, la forma de combatirla es no
imprimiendo billetes.
Así que sacó una nueva divisa, el REAL
BRASILEÑO.
Una divisa que, por ley, estaba fijada al
dólar.
Esto significa que el Banco Central no podía
imprimir dinero a su antojo porque la equivalencia
entre el REAL y el DÓLAR, debía seguir siendo
la misma.
Y justo, de un año para otro, esa hiperinflación
que sufrían los brasileños desapareció.
Fijaros en la gráfica porque se ve clarísimamente.
Tras la introducción del Real, los precios
se estabilizaron automáticamente.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque todo esto
es más complicado de lo que parece!
El hecho de que un país deje de imprimir
billetes significa que ya no pueden gastar
a discreción.
Por eso, cuando Henrique Cardoso llegó a
ser presidente del país, en 1995, tuvo que
llevar a cabo un intenso programa de privatizaciones.
“Brasil permitirá la mayor entrada de capital
extranjero de todo Latino América en campos
como la generación eléctrica, las telecomunicaciones
y las autopistas”
Sin embargo, en contra de lo que podríais
pensar, estas privatizaciones no generaron
protestas.
Más bien todo lo contrario.
Por primera vez en su historia, los brasileños
podían hacer sus compras sin tener que hipotecarse.
Y esto beneficiaba, sobretodo, a las clases
más desfavorecidas.
A fin de cuentas, las clases altas siempre
habían tenido sus ahorros en dólares americanos,
por lo que la hiperinflación no les afectaba.
Pero, ¡no sólo eso!
El hecho de tener una divisa estable significa
un entorno de negocios estable.
De repente, Brasil se convirtió en un país
donde se podía invertir.
Y así es como comenzó…
LA DÉCADA DORADA DE BRASIL
En el año 2002, Cardoso no podía volverse
a presentar a las elecciones porque la Constitución
Brasileña, al igual que la Estadounidense,
limita los mandatos de los presidentes.
Y el nuevo presidente que eligieron los brasileños
fue este señor que veis aquí, que se llamaba
IGNACIO LULA DA SILVA.
Probablemente casi todos los que veáis este
vídeo hayáis oído hablar de él.
Lula era todo un símbolo de ese resurgir
de la izquierda latinoamericana.
Pero, a diferencia de otros políticos de
su generación como Hugo Chávez, Lula no
encabezó ninguna revolución.
En realidad, su política económica fue una
continuación del trabajo que había hecho
Cardoso: estabilidad monetaria, seguridad
jurídica y políticas sociales.
“Lula da Silva dijo ayer que su gobierno
priorizará la lucha contra el hambre, pero
advirtió que no hay ningún milagro para
resolver los problemas sociales y económicos
del país.”
La llegada de Lula al poder coincidió con
un subidón en los precios de las materias
primas.
Los productores de soja, azúcar o ciertos
minerales estaban en su mejor momento.
En otras palabras, todo aquello que Brasil
exportaba, se vendía a precios más altos
de lo normal.
A eso le sumas la seguridad jurídica y un
mercado de 200 millones de habitantes y entiendes
por qué Brasil estaba de moda.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Por qué Lula da Silva
se convirtió en semejante rock star en el
panorama político internacional?
La verdad es que el presidente de Brasil aprovechó
ese torrente de dinero que entraba en el país
para acabar con la pobreza.
Hablamos de uno de los países más desiguales
de todo el continente.
Cuando Lula llegó al gobierno, casi el 40%
de la población seguía viviendo en condiciones
de pobreza extrema.
Por eso, su política estrella, el programa
“BOLSA FAMILIA” sonaba como un maná caído
del cielo.
“No es perfecto, pero este programa ha sacado
de la pobreza a 22 millones de personas sin
arruinar al gobierno de Brasil”
Concretamente, este programa Bolsa Familia
consistía en una subvención que se daba,
directamente, a las familias que enviaban
a sus hijos al colegio.
Para recibir ese dinero, tenían que probar
que, efectivamente, los niños estaban escolarizados
y asistían a las clases.
De esta forma, el Gobierno mataba a dos pájaros
de un tiro: se aseguraba de que los niños
se educaban y, a la vez, sacaba a millones
de familias de la pobreza.
Este junto con otros programas, sirvió para
crear una pujante clase media brasileña.
¡No sólo eso!
Al sacar a tantísima gente de la pobreza,
Brasil se convertía en algo más que un lugar
perfecto para la mano de obra barata.
De repente, Brasil se convirtió en un mercado
atractivo para todo tipo de empresas.
Es en esta época cuando grandes multinacionales
como el Banco Santander o Master Card abren
oficinas en el país.
Tras décadas de hiperinflación, pobreza
extrema y violencia en las calles, Brasil
se convertía en la gran promesa de Latino
América.
¡Pero esperad un momento porque aquí no
termina la cosa!
En el año 2008, cuando el resto del mundo
empezaba a sufrir los efectos de la crisis
económica, los brasileños descorchaban champan
con esta noticia.
“Los descubrimientos de petróleo en alta
mar podrían convertir a Brasil en uno de
los principales exportadores de crudo”
¿Qué más se puede pedir?
¡Los brasileños lo tenían todo!
Y para celebrarlo, el Comité Olímpico les
concedió el honor de ser el país anfitrión
de los Juegos Olímpicos del año 2016.
Brasil estaba en todos los periódicos económicos.
Los ciudadanos consumían como si no existiera
mañana.
Y los que hacemos este canal, Alberto, Couto
y yo, asistíamos a cursos de política donde
nos decían que teníamos que hacer las maletas
y marcharnos a Sao Paulo, donde no nos faltaría
trabajo…
Sin embargo, y como ya sabéis… este optimismo
duró bastante poco.
Sí, es cierto, comparado con Argentina, Brasil
era un paraíso de seguridad jurídica.
Pero también era un país con unos precios
totalmente desorbitados para el salario medio
que disfrutaban los brasileños.
Todo eso, por no hablar de los tremendos aranceles
que imponían al comercio exterior.
O de la corrupción que todavía no se conocía,
pero que estaba pudriendo los cimientos del
país.
Pero de todo eso seguiremos hablando en las
próximas semanas.
Hoy, vamos a cerrar este vídeo con eso que
dicen en las series de televisión: TO BE
CONTINUED.
Si no os queréis perder ese vídeo que sacaremos
próximamente, no olvidéis en suscribiros
al canal.
Mientras tanto, si queréis empezar a entender
por qué Brasil es una economía disfuncional,
podéis hacer click en este otro vídeo.
Y ahora la pregunta es… ¿Por qué creéis
que Brasil ha terminado con semejante crisis
cuando, en principio, todo apuntaba a que
iban por el buen camino?
¿De verdad puede el escándalo Odebrecht
jugar un rol tan importante en la crisis brasileña?
Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en los comentarios.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto!